in order to understand the Iranian
nuclear negotiations you need to
understand the trilateral relationship
between the United States Israel and
Iran first blush it seems very simple
the United States and Israel are allies
they're both opposed to Iran but the way
these negotiations have gone down
severely complicated the matter to
understand why we need to look at the
individual personalities that are
involved in the negotiations first off
and perhaps most importantly as
President Obama resolving the Iranian
nuclear standoff peacefully as a major
foreign policy priority for President
Obama however it's difficult to resolve
given supreme leader Ayatollah Ali
Khamenei is rather hostile to Western
interests specifically the United States
however while he does have final control
over the Iranian government he can be
pushed by a factions inside Iran
specifically more moderate ones that are
interested in sanctions relief in
exchange for a deal president Hassan
rouhani is widely seen as one of these
moderate figures and his 2013 election
suggested to many Americans that Iran
and the Supreme Leader might be willing
to make a deal
this has infuriated America's ally in
Israel it's Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu sees the Iranian nuclear
program as an existential threat we need
a better deal a different deal because
this deal would leave Iran with
sufficient capability 6,000 centrifuges
enables them to break out to a bomb very
quickly this is put Netanyahu at odds
with Obama an order to deal with this
disagreement he's turned to Republicans
in the United States I've invited Prime
Minister of Israel but Benjamin
Netanyahu to address a joint session of
Congress that's why this deal is so bad
it doesn't block Iran's path to the bomb
it paves Iran's path to the bomb 47
Republican senators put their names
today to this open letter to Iran this
type of alliance between a foreign
leader and a domestic American
opposition is basically unprecedented
so you've got a strange situation where
the United States is at loggerheads with
its closest ally in the Middle East
where the United States is divided
amongst itself on foreign policy and
where you've got President Obama
desperately trying to bolster the
standing of moderates inside Iran a
country the United States has regarded
as a serious enemy since 1979